[Musique]
il est mort en plein adolescence
il a souffert de famine et de douleurs
atroces
ça ange droite était ravagée par une
bactérie à tel point qu'il marchait avec
une béquille
ce jeune irlandais a été enterré dans
une fosse commune dans le quartier
Pointe Saint-Charles à Montréal c'était
en 1847
aujourd'hui pour la première fois depuis
175 ans il parle on les a sortis c'est
pas juste des squelettes dans des boîtes
là on a une histoire associée à chacun
d'eux
ce matin 4 représentants de la
communauté irlandaise de Montréal sont
réunis dans les bureaux d'ethnoscope à
Boucherville
la bio archéologue marine Puech va lever
le voile sur une période douloureuse de
leur passé
puis reconstituer un peu même sa
démarche dans son vivant une fenêtre
s'ouvre sur l'ancien cimetière ou repose
6000 irlandais des immigrants arrivés
par bateau est mort du typhus on sent
d'un coup plus proches on rentre dans
leur vie on rentre dans leur dans leur
quotidien
aujourd'hui à part une énorme roche
noire gravée à la mémoire des disparus
rien ne laisse deviner la présence d'un
cimetière dans le quartier
le site se trouve à proximité de
l'autoroute Bonaventure en pleine zone
industrielle
il est traversé par la rue Bridge qui
mène au pont Victoria et depuis peu par
le Réseau Express métropolitain le REM
on aurait pu éviter de mettre un pilier
dans cimetière mais en fait ça aurait
été une structure très très imposante en
fait il y aurait fallu construire un
pont
en optimisant leur tracé et leur
structure les ingénieurs du REM arrivent
à mettre un seul pilier dans l'enceinte
du cimetière plutôt que les deux prévus
initialement
pour ancrer ce pilier dans le rock il va
falloir forer un pieu de 3 mètres de
diamètre sur 12 mètres de profondeur
Elisabeth Boivin contacte les
représentants de la communauté
irlandaise et leur propose de mener des
fouilles archéologiques et c'est très
sensible l'idée d'aller faire une
fouille archéologique dans un cimetière
alors très rapidement on a tissé des
liens avec eux
pour mener des fouilles à l'intérieur
d'un caisson de 3 mètres de diamètre il
faut faire preuve d'imagination
en novembre 2019 trois archéologues des
centres tours à tours dans une nacelle
conçue sur mesure suspendue au bout
d'une grue
donc quand on est dans le fond du pilier
on voit juste un petit bout du ciel puis
on se sent un peu un petit peu seul
là-dedans
lors du premier essai la nacelle descend
sur un peu moins de 6 mètres
c'est la profondeur à laquelle les
archéologues pensent que se trouvent le
cimetière donc la nacelle était munie de
Trappes 6 petites trappes qui ont la
forme de pointe de camembert
puis là on allait faire des tests à
l'appel
lors des premières descentes les
archéologues ne voient rien
qu'en nacelle se retire et l'excavatrice
poursuit son boulot
jusqu'à ce qu'on commence à voir de la
chaux à l'époque on utilisait la chaux
pour contenir les odeurs d'après les
archives qu'on a lu par exemple les
annales des sœurs grises c'était assez
pestilentiel merci quand ils annoncent
un peu les cadavres avant de les mettre
en cercueil puis les enterrer
marine puait redescend dans la nacelle
cette fois ça y est elle trouve des
planches de cercueil
on a réussi tout ce qu'on a mis en
oeuvre ça a fonctionné
les vestiges sont exceptionnellement
bien conservés
quand on enlève le la première planche
puis que on voit dessous il y a
quelqu'un ouais ça fait quelque chose ça
fait quelque chose
en 1845 une épidémie de mildiou ravages
des champs de pommes de terre en Irlande
la famine s'installe
entre 1847 et 1848 100 000 irlandais
vont émigrés au Canada
ils font le voyage entassés dans les
cales de bateaux le typhus propagé par
les poux de corps se répand comme une
traînée de poudre à bord des navires
les survivants descendent à grossir où
se trouve un centre de quarantaine
ceux qui sont jugés en bonne santé pour
suivre le voyage jusqu'à Montréal
on ignore à l'époque que la durée
d'incubation de la bactérie responsable
du typhus et de 10 à 15 jours
des milliers d'immigrants tombent
malades lorsqu'ils arrivent à Montréal
ils ont pas d'argent ils ont pas
beaucoup de vêtements et ils peuvent pas
ni la française ni l'anglais
les Soeurs Grises soignent les malades
dans des baraques à Pointe-Saint-Charles
des morts
malgré ses efforts jusqu'à 30 malades
des 7 chaque jour il faut les enterrer
en vitesse
[Musique]
au fond du caisson dans l'ancien
cimetière marine puait dessine les
planches que la perçoit les cercueils
sont hexagonaux et leur tête pointent
vers le nord
l'équipe exhume les sépultures et
découvre rapidement un deuxième étage de
cercueil ils optimiser l'espace on ouvre
une fausse faut mettre un maximum de
personnes dedans
au total les archéologues vont exhumer
les restes de 14 individus 7 adultes 4
adolescents et trois enfants
ils analysent pour s'étaler sur plus de
deux ans
elles vont révéler un niveau de détails
inouï sur les origines et le parcours de
ces hommes et ses femmes au destin
brisés
pour déterminer le sexe des individus
les bio-archéologues mesurent les eaux
du bassin
pour estimer l'âge chez les tout-petits
ils regardent le stade d'éruption des
dents
pour les adolescents ou les jeunes
adultes ils examinent les eaux longs
plus spécifiquement la partie qu'on
appelle les épices par exemple cette
épicerie est-elle fusionnée à celle-là
si c'est non c'est parce que il a moins
d'un certain âge ou plus dans certaines
âges
durant la croissance les extrémités des
eaux qu'on appelle les épiphises sont
séparés de la partie centrale la
diaphyse il fusionne progressivement
jusqu'à l'âge de 25 ou 30 ans
jeune homme à la béquille serait mort à
l'âge de 15 ans
marine puige a trouvé plusieurs marques
de traumatismes sur le corps du jeune
homme
cette deuxième côte du côté gauche est
fracturée là c'est comme fissuré sous la
force d'un impact direct à ce niveau-là
a été sévèrement attaquée par une
infection
c'est tout pour souffler il y a beaucoup
de grosses et de petites porosité ça
c'est vraiment un signe qu'il y avait
une infection active au moment du décès
l'infection affecter sa démarche
[Musique]
c'est complètement atrophié
son avant-bras gauche lui est plus
robuste que le droit c'est ce qui fait
penser qu'il utilisait une béquille
comme si il devait vraiment s'appuyer
sur quelque chose pour essayer à avancer
parce que clairement il pouvait peu ou
pas utiliser sa jambe infectée
le corps du jeune homme aurait attendu
une ou deux journées avant d'être
enterré
c'est ce que des chercheurs ont conclu
en analysant les fragments d'insectes
des composants retrouvés dans la terre
dans un tout petit cercueil les
archéologues ont trouvé les ossements
d'un bébé
selon marine Puech il était affamé au
moment de sa mort
les indices sur son âge sont
contradictoires
lorsqu'elles regardent le stade
d'éruption des dents la bio-archéologue
estime qu'il avait entre 6 et 12 mois au
moment du décès
mais la longueur de ces eaux comme les
fémur laisse croire qu'il n'avait qu'un
mois et demi l'âge dentaire est plus
avancé que l'âge osseux puis c'est ce
qui se passe quand il y a un retard de
croissance qui est dû à un stress
alimentaire une carence ou n'importe
quoi d'autre c'est que ça va d'abord
aller impacter le développement la
croissance des eaux avant d'aller en
vacances le développement des dents on
peut clairement affirmer que cette ce
petit bébé là a souffert avant de mourir
dans une autre sépulture les
archéologues ont trouvé les ossements
d'un homme d'âge adulte lui mettez
toujours ça pue au même endroit ouais
à cheval entre les canines et les
molaires gauche une usure concave s'est
formée c'est là qu'il plaçait sa pipe en
argile
[Musique]
ses dents révèlent d'autres indices sur
son passé
ces incisives supérieures sur la face
arrière semble avoir été polie par la
langue des fragments ce sont détachés ça
nous laisse penser que probablement il
utilisait sa bouche dans le cas de son
d'une activité professionnelle
quelconque va les petites chances que ça
pourrait par exemple le passage d'une
aiguille si tenez une aiguille entre ses
dents ou alors qu'il utilise vraiment ça
marche presque comme troisièmement
[Musique]
dans un autre cercueil c'est une femme
qu'on a trouvée
elle souffrait probablement d'anémie
sévère
son crâne est couvert de lésions poreuse
chez des anémiques le manque de fer
détruit les globules rouges responsables
de transporter l'oxygène dans le sang le
corps tente de compenser en en
fabriquant davantage
l'une des usines de production des
globules rouges se trouve justement dans
le crâne dans une partie spongieuse
qu'on appelle la diploé ça va faire
transparaître justement
l'architecture spongieuse de l'os donc
c'est pour ça qu'on va voir qui apparaît
à la surface du crâne
les techniques de pointe en archéologie
vont révéler beaucoup d'autres
informations sur le parcours des 14
individus
des analyses menées sur les dents ont
révélé qu'il venait d'Irlande de l'Ouest
et d'Irlande du Sud
on a même montré à quel moment ils ont
cessé de manger des pommes de terre pour
s'alimenter avec du maïs importés en
Irlande pour faire face à la famine
ces jours-ci on tente d'extraire de
l'ADN des ossements pour faire des
analyses génétiques
les membres de la communauté rêvent de
retracer les familles des 14 irlandais
enterrés de façon anonyme à Montréal
c'est des personnes
on veut de savoir si on peut pas te
donner un des noms
une fois les recherches complétées les
membres de la communauté contient les 14
dépouilles dans un Parc commémoratif qui
sera aménagé sur le site
ils seront mis en terre avec le respect
et l'honneur qui n'ont pas eu en 1847
leur histoire parlera au nom des 6000
autres
[Musique]